♪ (fanfare) ♪- - - - - - - - - r
président de gauche de
l'histoire de la Colombie,
est maintenant bien en place
(applaudissements)
Il devra gouverner avec
un Congrès très diversifié
qu
En vertu de l'accord de paix de
2016, il compte cinqeueueueurs
et cinq députés issus de
la guérilla des FARC et, pour ls
des victimes du conflit armé
venus des régions les plus
affectées.
des photos de disparus.
Le derni l l l la gauche,
c'est Jorge Rodrigo Tovar,
dont l'élection comme vict s s e
partie de la Colombie.
On veut annuler son poste,
certains veulent même sa tête.
de Colombiens, dit-il.
como la grand mayoría
de Colombianos.
- C'est parce que son père est
un des paramilitaires les plus
sanguinaires de ladrdrdrdrdrdrds
Jorge 40, auteur de centaines
d'assassinats et de massacres
de sympathisants présumés de
de prison aux États-Unis pour
trafic de drogue; maintenant,
il est emprisonné pour 40 ans
en Col
"J'aime beaucoup mon père
parce que c'est èèèère, mais
je ne suis pas responsable
ni juge de mon père."ilililililu
que derrière des barreaux une
quinzaine de minutes à la fois.
"Je suis la première victime
quand mon père a rejoint lesautn
de mon père. Je me suis réfugié
chez un
de père, Sergio Tovar; on l'a
assassiné le 24 décembre 2
- Eso!
avocat de formation, a choisi
ce villageigigigigènes Arhuaco
pour des raisons de sécurité,
mais aussi parce qu'il est d d t
le plus souffert du conflit armé
colombien.
♪♪♪♪ ♪
Nous sommes au coeur de
paramilitaire par excellence,ene
Santa Marta et de Perija,
qui étaien
de la guérilla.
..c court plein son
Jorge Tovar a pris le chemin
de l'exil, ce qui lui a valu
Depuis son retour il y a 8 ans,
il dit qu'il n'a jamais cessé
de militer pour les droits des
que les problèmes se règlent
par la parole,scscscscussion,
le débat et non un fusil
sur la poitrine. Ce sera g g g "
Beaucoup de ses collègues
au Congrès ne le croient pas.
Luis Alberto Alban représente
une victime, dit-il.
Il soupçonne Jorge Tovar
d'avoir acheté ses votes avecde.
INGRID BETANCOURT,
parti vert oxygène
- Son histoire est un petit peu
victime parce qu'il a vécu
trtrtrtrecoup de toutes
les affaires de son père.
(soupir)"P"P"P"P"P"P"P"P"P"P"P"s
de victimes du conflit,
je représente un territoire
abandonné par l'État,
conséquences de la guerre
dans ce pays."
♪ (fanfare) ♪
Depuis
Jorge Tovar dit qu'il a
maintenant quatre ans pour
prouver sa sincérité et
donner tort à ses détracteurs.
Radio-Canada, Valledupar.